bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir la dystopie de la rentrée
littéraire à ne surtout pas rater
bonsoir Lilia Hassen ravi de vous
accueillir dans cette émission panorama
et votre troisième roman chez Gallimard
roman policier cette fois qui se déroule
en 2049 dans une société de la
transparence poussée à l'extrême
jusqu'où peut-on sacrifier sa propre
liberté pour garantir sa sécurité c'est
l'une des nombreuses questions au cœur
de votre livre on va en parler
longuement toutes les deux tout à
l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
comment en finir avec le harcèlement
scolaire Elisabeth borne a dévoilé son
plan d'action il y a quelques heures
après les différences scandales et des
drames de ces dernières semaines réseaux
sociaux formation du personnel scolaire
justice les mesures annoncées sont elles
à la hauteur de l'électrochoc attendu
nous en débattons dans un tout petit
instant avec mes invités sur ce plateau
enfin nos affranchis ce soir l'Europe
avec
Richard Werly l’œil sur le numérique
avec Thomas l'estavel et puis un Bourbon
Express spécial budget 2024 sous la
loupe de Fanny guinochet voilà pour le
programme on y va il est à Seine ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
Lucas 13 ans en janvier Lindsay 13 ans
en juin Nicolas 15 ans en septembre
trois enfants harcelés qui ont mis fin à
leur jour et il y en a d'autres dans
cette année des morts qui signent
l'échec de la société à combattre ce
fléau il y a donc un plan d'action sur
la table annoncé en grand pompe avec
toute une kyrielle de ministre et
Elisabeth borne en tête se donne-t-il
les moyens ce gouvernement pour
combattre ce fléau bonsoir Perrine
Goulet bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
d'être député MoDem de la Nièvre vous
présidez la délégation au droit des
enfants ici même à l'Assemblée nationale
vous débattez ce soir avec Sarah le
grain bonsoir bienvenue député la France
insoumise de Paris bonsoir Nora
thierrane Fraysse merci d'être là vous
êtes délégué général de l'association
Marion la main tendue votre fils et
Marion qui a été harcelé à l'école
c'était il y a 10 ans elle a mis fin à
ses jours et depuis vous faites partie
du programme phare qui est mis en place
on en parlera dans les collèges et dans
les lycées pour lutter contre ce fléau
enfin bonsoir Bruno Bob qui évite
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
professeur du grand lycée Buffon dans le
15e arrondissement de Paris et vous êtes
aussi secrétaire général du syndicat
d'enseignant CNB TD en je voulais
signaler quand même Lilia Essen que
évidemment vous êtes largement partie
prenante à ce débat parce que vous en
parlez ce thème là dans votre dans votre
livre et à un personnage qui est victime
de harcèlement donc vous êtes aussi
journaliste n'hésitez pas à intervenir
dans ce débat on va commencer par
planter le décor
quelles sont ses annonces et bien c'est
évidemment Stéphane blackovski le chrono
de Blacko pour commencer
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et à tous je me retourne pour
vous accueillir caddie la première
ministre notamment
la première ministre qui est en personne
est venue présenter le plan
anti-harcèlement scolaire du
gouvernement mais faut connaître que
jusqu'à présent c'était quand même
plutôt Gabriel Attal qui était en
première ligne donc le ministre a été
nommé il y a trois mois et il souhaite
que créer un électrochoc dans l'opinion
autour de la question du harcèlement
donc il a utilisé plusieurs ficelles on
va dire de communication ou d'action par
exemple jouer sur l'émotion qu'on a
ressenti en voyant les suicides
d'enfants victimes de harcèlement il est
cite nommément vous voyez il énumère le
nom des victimes dans ses discours ou
même dans des tweets et puis parmi les
signes forts envoyés depuis la rentrée
il y a eu les interpellations par la
police de harceleur dans leurs écoles ou
encore les propos très sévères de
Gabriel Attal contre l'académie de
Versailles qui avait envoyé des
courriers menaçants à des parents dans
les enfants qui était harcelé donc le
résultat c'est que depuis la rentrée le
harcèlement scolaire fait vraiment à la
Une assez régulièrement des médias et ça
semble avoir libéré en quelque sorte la
parole c'est ce que dit Gabriel Attal en
se fiant à un chiffre celui des appels
au 30 18 qui est le numéro mis à
disposition des victimes de harcèlement
et bien ça s'appelle ont été multipliés
par 3 cette rentrée par rapport à la
rentrée dernière donc il y a une
libération de la parole c'est d'ailleurs
le premier axe sur lequel compte
travailler le gouvernement libérer la
parole dont détecter au plus tôt les cas
de harcèlement et pour ça une nouvelle
mesure va être mis en place elle était
annoncée par Elisabeth borne en l'écoute
pour identifier les dangers tous les
élèves du CE2 à la troisième rempliront
chaque année une grille
d'auto-évaluation qui permettra de
repérer les cas de harcèlement et
d'intervenir rapidement alors le
deuxième axe du plan du gouvernement
contre le harcèlement c'est la
prévention dans ce domaine Gabriel Attal
ne se cache pas de cette inspiré de ce
qui se passe au Danemark où on a mis en
place des méthodes de lutte contre
largement depuis vraiment longtemps
depuis une vingtaine d'années dans
certaines écoles en l'occurrence les
Danois constaté que c'était pas
suffisant de punir simplement les
harceleurs mais qu'il fallait dès les
plus jeunes nages donner des cours aux
enfants pour leur faire comprendre les
mécanismes du harcèlement pour qu'ils
puissent y échapper pour leur apprendre
à être plus empathique les uns envers
les autres on écoute Gabriel Attal les
cours d'empathie les cours de respect de
l'autre d'apprentissage du respect de
soi et des autres les compétences
psychosociales la France va donc
inscrire dans le cursus scolaire des
cours d'empathie sur le modèle de ce qui
existe dans d'autres pays notamment au
Danemark où je me suis rendu et puis il
y a donc un troisième axe que le
gouvernement appelle solution en fait
qui consacrer surtout aux sanctions on
peut prendre contre les harceleurs donc
la première ministre a annoncé qu'il y
aurait une saisine systématique du
procureur quand il y a un signalement de
harcèlement qui va faire donc pas mal de
travail pour la justice et comme le
harcèlement se déroule essentiellement
sur les réseaux enfin essentiellement
aussi en grande partie sur les réseaux
sociaux bien on a durci certaines
sanctions
à ce propos on écoute donc Jean-Louis le
Maroc qui lui est ministre délégué au
numérique
prévu une mesure qui permettra au juge
lorsqu'il décidera de condamner l'auteur
d'un fait de cyber-harcèlement scolaire
de prendre une peine complémentaire de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux pendant
une période de six mois qui peut être
portée à un an en cas de récidive alors
bien sûr j'ai pas fait la liste
exhaustive des mesures compris les
frères détection prévention
solutions
simplement il y a pas de doute le
gouvernement cherche vraiment à lutter
contre ce phénomène mais c'est pas
nouveau enfin tous les ministres depuis
2010 ont proposé des plans entières
seulement je vous laisse regarder j'ai
pris les archives en 2011 c'était Luc
Châtel en 2013 Vincent Peillon le plan
harcèlement de Najat Vallaud-Belkacem
c'était en 2015 en 2019 il y a eu un
nouveau plan proposé par Jean-Michel
Blanquer donc évidemment la question ce
soir c'est est-ce que le nouveau plan à
la base est par le gouvernement sera
plus efficace que les plans précédents
merci beaucoup Stéphane on va entrer
évidemment dans le détail des mesures
mais moi je voudrais vous entendre
d'abord nos rafrais sur le moment qu'on
traverse le ministre de l'Éducation
Gabriel Attal a dit un tsunami de
témoignages arrivent sur les numéros
d'appel le 30 20 est-ce que on est face
une forme de de Me Too du harcèlement
aussi bien des des enfants victimes que
leurs parents appellent est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est en train de traverser
un tournant sur ce sur ce sujet là je
pense que c'est pas un tsunami de
signalement c'est la révélation de cas
qui n'ont pas déjà été traitées depuis
des mois et des années ensuite on nous
dit une augmentation de trois fois mais
trois fois trois fois plus et trois fois
plus de quoi de combien pardon je suis
très pragmatique et compliqué de
connaître bah non c'est pas compliqué
non je les ai pas je sais que le 30/20
c'était autour de 90 000 sollicitations
et le 318 autour de 25000 mais
je veux pas faire peur aux gens se dire
si il y en a trois fois plus que j'en
avais dit c'est du coup j'en ai 30 ok
mais il faut être très très précis il
faut pas faire peur aux gens donc l'idée
que la parole se libère que au fond la
peur change de camps non c'est pas que
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec c'est pas
que la parole se libère elle s'est
libérée depuis de nombreuses années
depuis 8 à 9 ans mais elle n'était pas
recueillie entendue et prise en charge
simplement la ce qui est évoqué avec
l'Académie de Versailles c'est quelque
chose qu'on révèle depuis des années moi
j'avais rencontré des gens au ministère
au mois d'avril j'avais demandé comment
on dit audience et je leur ai dit vous
êtes assis sur une poudrière aujourd'hui
on a des gens qui sont désemparés des
familles qui nous appellent qui n'ont
pas de solution au mois d'août vers le
15 août on commençait à avoir des emails
et des appels pour nous dire je demande
un changement d'affectation pour mon
enfant je ne veux pas qu'il retourne
avec ses bourreaux donc en fait il vient
d'arriver il y a vraiment envie de
changer les choses mais il découvre
quelque chose que nous que nous que nous
connaissiez depuis toujours et que vous
dénonciez depuis tout et on nous disait
allez voir ailleurs si j'y suis et bah
là on y est vraiment là les gens sont en
souffrance et surtout beaucoup de
parents nous ont appelé en nous disant
ça veut vraiment dire que si c'est pas
pris en charge mon enfant peut se
suicider elle est là la peur des parents
c'est pour ça que tous ces signalements
en disant on m'a mal répondu
des mesures qui ont été annonces il y en
a tellement si on va venir voilà c'est
compliqué ouais enfin on va y venir dans
le détail mais parce que on entend
beaucoup cette idée de d'un changement
d'une sorte de libération de la parole
parce que au fond les élèves leurs
parents n'auraient plus peur vous vous
voyez ça
phénomène massif les mots sont forts
c'est compliqué d'évaluer on dit un
enfant sur 10 d'après le rapport du
Sénat était harcelé dans notre pays ne
sont pas redirigées vers les
établissements scolaires donc c'est
c'est difficile pour nous d'évaluer ces
situations je pense qu'elles sont très
diverses en fonction aussi des types
d'établissements collèges lycée école on
n'est pas sur le même problématique et
c'est difficile pour nous de le savoir
c'est une problématique que nous
traitons au quotidien dans notre gestion
d'établissement on a effectivement un
certain nombre de situations que nous
sommes amenés à traiter il faut
l'admettre donc il faut admettre aussi
que dans un grand majorité de situations
on est capable de les traiter notamment
dans les situations où l'auteur la
victime sont claire identifié il n'y a
pas de discussion sur le problème
enseignants mais par l'institution c'est
ce que révèle quand même le scandale de
l'académie de Versailles du rectorat sur
le terrain on a pas cette impression
mais à partir du moment où il y a un
certain nombre de personnages impliqués
des associations qui le disent il faut
être capable de l'entendre voilà on peut
pas rejeter le sujet en considérant que
l'éducation nationale n'a pas sa part de
responsabilité dans cette affaire tout
comme les réseaux sociaux tout comme les
parents ont une responsabilité dans la
gestion de ses affaires alors on y vient
sur les mesures on va parler d'abord de
l'école est-ce que déjà pour vous c'est
le problème premier de l'école parce
qu'on n'a pas entendu le mot parent
vraiment dans ce dans ce plan est-ce que
si on résout les problèmes au niveau
scolaire mais les moyens on parviendra à
stopper ce fléau là à votre avis alors
le harcèlement le mot harcèlement et
récent mais en fait le harcèlement à
l'école on l'a tous vécu étant petit
sous d'autres mots mais c'était déjà pas
normal à l'époque qu'on se laisse taper
intimider dans nos cours d'école quand
nous nous étions jeunes la grosse
différence aujourd'hui c'est que avant
je veux dire quand un enfant était
maltraité à l'école ça s'arrêtait à la
sortie de l'école et rentrer chez lui il
était dans un cocon où il était protégé
la problématique aujourd'hui c'est que
ça ne s'arrête pas c'est à dire l'enfant
est harcelé physiquement à l'école et
quand il rentre chez lui il y a encore
les réseaux sociaux il y a encore le
numérique qui appuie et donc ça ne
s'arrête jamais et c'est certes un sujet
pour l'école mais je veux dire le
harcèlement maintenant même quand on
change un enfant d'école parfois le
harcèlement continue donc on a pour moi
et vous l'avez très justement dit au
départ c'est un échec de la société tout
entière il faut vraiment qu'on agisse du
dès le plus jeune âge déjà pour que
l'enfant sache que c'est qu'être victime
parce qu'aujourd'hui si on explique pas
enfants bien que ce qu'on lui fait subir
ces mal mais on peut pas il peut pas le
deviner et donc ça je pense que c'est
important c'est pour ça qu'en plus les
cours comme le propose Gabriel Attal
alors moi sont très intéressants puisque
la bienveillance moi en tout cas je me
bats depuis plusieurs années pour qu'on
ait une éducation au corps avec cette
bienveillance mais c'est pour apprendre
à l'école qu'on doit apprendre son ami
son camarade c'est le lieu c'est pas le
le rôle des parents alors c'est le rôle
des parents bien entendu mais je veux
dire il y a aussi malheureusement des
parents en difficulté il faut qu'on ait
des soutiens la parentalité plus
important devant les enjeux qu'on a
maintenant qui sont pas les enjeux il y
a quelques années mais il faut aussi que
l'école bien jouent son rôle on sait que
l'école est le le premier pourvoyeur
d'informations préoccupante parce que il
faut pas se leurrer il y a aussi des
familles qui dysfonctionnent et moi
pourquoi je plaide pour éducation au
corps dès la maternelle c'est pour que
dès la maternelle les enfants sachent
bien que la loi qu'on a votée en 2019
sur les violences éducatives ordinaires
sont une réalité pour qu'on explique aux
enfants que dans être dans la société
c'est pas réagir quand on va pas bien
par des coûts donner aux autres et je
pense que ça commence par là et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut absolument qu'on ait
cette éducation au corps à la
bienveillance dès la matinée
de la prévention c'est la grande
question vous vous avez enseigné c'est
ça vous êtes enseignante toujours
mais je suis effectivement le français
saignante de français j'ai enseigné
longtemps en Seine-Saint-Denis
moi je ma première conviction c'est
qu'effectivement
la question des violences entre les
enfants c'est une question d'adulte
c'est une question qui interpelle tous
les adultes le fait que des enfants sauf
soient conduits comme comme ça a été le
cas pour le vôtre de mettre fin à leurs
jours c'est une question qui interpelle
tous les adultes et tout la société les
violences qui ont lieu entre en France
ce sont des violences qui sont
alimentées par de la violence qu'il y a
dans la société vous parliez de
révélation faisait le parallèle avec
Mitou et ben on est dans une société qui
est traversée par des violences faites
aux femmes et bien les harcèlements
entre enfants ils vont s'appuyer sur ces
violences sexistes on est dans une
société traversée par des violences
homophobes par des violences racistes
par des violences grossophobes toutes
ces violences là c'est un contexte dans
le vous citez
l'homophobie et les situations de
handicap ce sont les trois premières
et donc la façon dont notre société déjà
fait prospérer ou traite ces violences
elle a un rôle sur la façon dont les
enfants ensuite perpétuent ces violences
pour ça que l'idée sur laquelle en
sortant de l'école avant ils étaient
dans un cocon bah non il y a des
violences dans le cadre intrafamilial
vous le savez très bien il y a des
violences donc voilà maintenant la
question c'est notre responsabilité
collective donc déjà il y a pas
d'hypocrises à avoir on peut pas ne pas
mener comme il faut le combat ne pas
donner aux associations de lutte contre
les violences excité sexuelles les deux
milliards les plus de milliards qu'elle
demande et on va revenir voilà ce que je
veux dire c'est que il faut adresser le
concert maintenant sur la question de
l'école et j'y tiens particulièrement
moi ce que ce que je vois dans ces
annonces c'est
je vois un paradoxe entre un ces
annonces là et un budget qui tombe
aujourd'hui où on apprend que c'est de
nouveau 2500 postes de professeurs qui
vont être enlevés donc la question de la
présence humaine démographique dans
certains classes qui ont démocratie
2017 si vous voulez ou alors il y a une
grosse grosse baisse démographique dans
le pays parce que 7900 profs supprimer
depuis 2017 je vous parle des profs 400
CPE en moins depuis 2017 2000 AED AED
c'est les surveillants en moins depuis
2017 et j'aimerais parler de la médecine
scolaire qui est un carnage dans l'état
enfin je pense que vous aimeriez dire
qu'il y a une vraie 900 médecins
scolaires pour 40 000 questions
très bien mais qui quelle va être la
personne humaine quand vous dites la
parole se libère mais il y a qui en face
pour accueillir cette parole des
formations très bien mais quand la
formation initiale des enseignants a été
sacrifiée toutes ces dernières années
des des profs qui vont faire des cours
d'empathie quelles heures de cours il y
a déjà pas assez d'heures de cours pour
faire les programmes et il y a déjà pas
assez de prof pour être devant les
classes alors là c'est la question
centrale c'est la question des moyens
évidemment des choses qui ont été faites
et depuis longtemps il y a des
sensibilisations des formations etc là
l'objectif ce serait de former tous les
personnels enseignants d'ici la fin du
quinquennat on n'a pas de chiffres on
sait pas pour vous voilà comment vous
accueillez ça vous vous dites c'est un
coup de com ou ce
matin c'est en dispositif qui va prendre
du temps il faut l'annoncer comme tel et
qui nécessite des moyens complémentaires
donc 800 000 enseignants près d'un
million de personnes à former ça va pas
se faire un coup de baguette magique en
quelques mois donc ça c'est un élément
important qu'il faut rappeler ensuite il
y a la question de je partage l'idée que
le dispositif de questionnaires
d'auto-évaluation peut être une bonne
idée qui
peut-être pas uniquement de ce que vous
êtes harcelé ou pas j'ai vu les projets
de questionnaire il y a une trentaine de
questions par élève qui récoltent ces
questionnaires moi dans mon
établissement il y a 1900 élèves donc
qui traite les 1900 questionnaires qui
sont des questionnaires papier et que
fait-on des réponses à partir du moment
où on considère que sur les 30 questions
posées régulièrement la question de
l'insécurité dans les toilettes etc se
pose quelle plan derrière quels moyens
allons-nous avoir pour répondre à la à
partir du moment on libère la parole et
on pose des questions il faut savoir y
répondre
c'est vrai que 3500 postes supprimés on
cherche 3000 profs aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs on a re-ouvert les fameux
jobs dating dans l'éducation on se dit
ce sont de belles promesses je pense
qu'effectivement il y a un sujet avec la
partie vocation des enseignants qui
avaient cours pendant plusieurs années
on peine à recruter les enseignants
c'est clair par contre le budget quand
même en haut cette année donc il y a
quand même des choses sur l'éducation
nationale qui qui bouge après on a un
sujet sur la formation là où je vous
rejoins ma fille est en cours de
formation pour être enseignante donc je
vois les lacunes de cette formation et
donc je m'en suis ouvert au ministre cet
après-midi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
revoit la formation précisément est-ce
que vous avez constaté concrètement
typiquement sur l'éducation à la
sexualité c'est quand même pour moi en
tout cas quelque chose d'important que
je vais coupler que l'éducation au corps
les enseignants sont pas forcément bien
encadrés pour pouvoir le faire la partie
harcèlement avec phare on a bien
développé la formation dans les collèges
sauf qu'on voit que le harcèlement c'est
pas qu'au collège on l'a peut-être cru
pendant un certain temps moi je constate
que des enseignants premier degré aux
primaires sont quand même en difficulté
pour pour gérer bien c'est ce
harcèlement peut-être parce que on n'a
pas alors j'entends bien qu'il y a des
des postes vacants sur la médecine
scolaire et c'est un vrai enjeu il faut
qu'on revoit s'il faut revaloriser pour
qu'on attire aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas
à tirer c'est pas qu'on veut les pas en
avoir parce qu'on n'arrive pas à tirer
et en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive
aujourd'hui en primaire on n'a pas de
procès médicaux à demeure dans les dans
toutes les établissements scolaires donc
de toute façon il faudra qu'on trouve
une solution pour accompagner les
enseignants et puis il y a aussi la
difficulté je veux peut-être plus dans
le primaire que que dans le secondaire
c'est que le primaire ils sont vraiment
au contact avec les familles avec les
parents et donc des fois faire des
informations préoccupantes signaler des
difficultés c'est un peu plus difficile
dans le dans le primaire parce que les
retombées et les j'allais dire les les
mécontentements peuvent revenir plus
vite qu'au collège où on est un peu
entre guillemets plus protégés donc je
pense que voilà ça va dans le bon sens
c'est au moins un plan interministériel
on a mené on a met on met le dedans la
justice on va parler des réseaux sociaux
la santé le num avec une phase la
semaine prochaine que j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir améliorer encore sur le texte
notamment en lien avec les droits de
l'enfant la semaine prochaine qu'on
puisse pas accéder à certaines choses
encore plus de manière importante bien
entendu ce plan il faudra qu'il évolue
parce que la société évolue parce que
les dangers évoluent au fur et à mesure
à peine annoncé
la majorité les limites elles mérite
d'être Jean-Paul c'est pour répondre à
ce que vous ayez tout à l'heure il y a
déjà eu x plan oui il y a déjà eu que ce
plan mais la société évolue de jour en
jour et donc à un moment il faut
absolument à chaque fois coller moi je
suis par contre convaincu
que la prévention est importante et j'en
reviens et je j'ai peut-être ce martel
en tête qui est vraiment pour moi le
plus important c'est cette éducation au
corps s'est éducation à la préservation
de son intégrité au respect des autres
qui est pour moi très important et qu'on
doit faire dès le premier les élèves le
savent non non pas tous
ils sont quand même informés même via
les réseaux sociaux ils savent que bon a
priori on ne fera pas un camarade enfin
ça c'est des choses qu'on apprend à
l'école maternelle non et que les
parents normalement doivent apprendre
leurs enfants mais quand vous avez des
familles dysfonctionnantes vous avez des
parents qui violent et on a une campagne
sur l'inceste en ce moment qui est
importante qui rappelle quand même la
force de l'inceste dans notre pays merci
à un enfant il n'y a pas par exemple
l'école qui lui explique que ce qui a
lieu dans sa famille ou ce qui a lieu à
tel ou tel endroit n'est pas normal bien
c'est il peut pas il peut pas le deviner
tout seul et je pense que
c'est pas que le problème de l'école
mais l'école peut accompagner pour pour
lutter contre toutes ces
sur l'institution scolaire
racontez-nous votre expérience et
dites-nous ce que vous en attendez
précisément je juste recentrer le débat
moi j'étais venu pour parler du
harcèlement je veux bien qu'on parle de
tout et un moment mais c'est vraiment le
sujet on nous parle absolument
on parle beaucoup des réseaux sociaux je
veux juste dire aux gens qui nous qui
nous regardent et qui nous appelle et
qui nous demande de l'aide
franchement avant 12 ans faut arrêter de
raconter des carabistes tout urgent en
disant on après après l'école ça nous
poursuit oui ça nous poursuit pas que
sur les réseaux sociaux ça nous poursuit
dans les transports scolaires à hauteur
de 50%, 15% dans les toilettes dans
quelque chose qui est notable c'est la
ministre des Sports on travaille
beaucoup avec le ministère des Sports
pour travailler justement sur
l'extrascolaire donc en fait il faut
agir dès le plus jeune âge dès la
maternelle il faut pas avoir peur de
mettre des moyens et oui il y a des
vrais décisions mais moi je peux pas
vous dire que tout est bien tant que je
ne sais je ne sais pas plusieurs choses
qu'elle va être quel va être le budget
alloué quel est l'objectif annoncé qui
va être le taux d'impact comment on a
évalué les cours d'empathie c'est très
bien mais dans la vraie vie ce sont pas
des cours d'empathie c'est le
développement des compétences
psychosociales ça demande donc de
l'expertise ça demande des personnes
donc voilà toute cette liste il faut pas
être sur promesse moi ce que je dis
c'est qu'aujourd'hui quoi qu'il arrive
nos enfants meurent encore du
harcèlement donc aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
eu de réponse à je vais empêcher des
enfants de se suicider façon harcèlement
je n'ai pas ces réponses on me dit mon
petit point net ou je sais pas quoi là
mon petit point net ça veut dire que
c'est dédié à des personnes qui vont
être derrière leur ordinateur mais il y
a des zones blanches à l'électronique il
y a des familles allophones pardon ça
fait 10 ans je suis sur le terrain
le dispose mon psy n'est pas que
internet c'est juste ça que je voulais
dire
la vie réelle également vous voyez ce
qui est grave c'est que ce qui est grave
c'est que je sais même pas de quoi il
s'agit ça veut dire que le commun des ne
comprend rien et c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un problème de
pédagogie moi ce que j'ai trouvé dans
cette dans cette conférence de presse
deux choses remarquables tout le monde
était autour de la table très
intéressant plan interministériel c'est
formidable mais on n'a rien compris il y
avait tellement d'informations moi je
suis parent à 16h30 avec mon enfant qui
sort de l'école qui prend le goûter je
me dis ça y est j'y vais j'écoute
c'était j'avais l'impression dans mon
ancienne vie d'être dans un pour ça que
direction je vais les vendre un projet
de me dire je vais avoir un budget la
question c'est combien de temps le
travail des médias aussi c'est d'essayer
de réexpliquer ça n'est pas qu'un seul
plan à 16h30 depuis maintenant les
choses vont prendre des personnes il
faut pas te surprenez et aujourd'hui
honnêtement je ne sais pas comment on va
agir dans les écoles dès le premier
degré comment nous les associations qui
mourront de fautes et pas que des
subventions de l'éducation nationale on
nous demande beaucoup avec peu et les
enfants ont besoin d'aide on a besoin de
remettre de l'humain faisait parallèle
allez avec les violences faites aux
femmes c'est très compliqué aujourd'hui
un enfant il est perdu sa femme et
toutes les familles sont pas
dysfonctionnel il se passe aussi vous
savez moi j'étais pas vous diriez que ça
avance plus vite sur la question des
violences faites aux femmes par rapport
au harcèlement puisque vous pouvez avoir
un enfant harceleur et un enfant harcelé
on remet j'entendais tout à l'heure on
va enlever les aides c'était pas le cas
mais un parent qui disait dans ce cas-là
faut enlever les aides aux parents
derrière ça veut dire que ce sont
toujours les pauvres les personnes
vulnérables qui auraient des enfants
solaires c'est là qu'on a besoin d'agir
et faire preuve de pédagogie mais pardon
6% d'augmentation du budget d'éducation
nationale combien sur cette cause
combien aux associations vous les avez
pas les réponses pour le moment non non
on n'a pas encore
honnêtement je peux pas vous répondre
aujourd'hui parce que les documents
budgétaires enseignement scolaire sont
pas tombés donc bien entendu j'ai vu
qu'il y avait la ligne budgétaire mais
on n'a pas le découpage dans chaque dans
chaque thématique bien entendu on sera
vigilant et je partage avec vous le fait
qu'il faut qu'on ait des moyens pour
pour mettre en place ce plan c'est plus
qu'une une nécessité parce que le
harcèlement c'est terrible pour pour les
suicides mais
on parle des suicides mais ça peut
détruire des enfants pour tout le reste
de leur vie également et donc on a
vraiment pour moi nécessité que on
accompagne mieux effectivement je
propose justement toutes les réponses
dedans mais en tout cas moi à la
délégation en temps présent de
l'aviation droit des enfants je vous
assure qu'on va qu'on va suivre parce
que ça fait partie des fratries et les
parents et les grands-parents il faut
qu'on accompagne
il faut qu'on accompagne et l'ensemble
est monté même si mon psy effectivement
c'est des séances à les témoignages mais
en plus il y aura je suis sûr que vous
aurez des choses
en dehors de ce studio écoutez ce
reportage s'il vous plaît Baptiste
gargui Chartier a rencontré à la fois
des victimes et des parents
d'adolescents victimes regardez
c'était il y a 30 ans
Ombeline victime d'harcèlement scolaire
lorsqu'elle était collégienne
brimades injures verbale à 44 ans elle
choisit enfin de libérer sa parole des
surnoms idiots faire des remarques sur
mon physique qui m'humidit qui me dit
enfin bon voilà et puis c'est passé
alors quelquefois pas de tous mais c'est
passé à des
démocris d'ordre
d'ordre sexuel des années après les
cicatrices sont encore là et ont bel et
bien laissé des traces
c'est des mots dont on sait même très
jeune qui sont très chargés et quand on
vous les dit négativement bah vous
prenez la charge en fait puis vous
l'accumulez
et ça fait mal
les témoignages comme celui-ci
fleurissent sur les réseaux sociaux ou
des anciens harcelets tant d'acter
ma fille harcelée en primaire je prends
rendez-vous avec le chef d'établissement
qui me dit qu'il ne peut rien faire il y
a 15 ans sans l'intervention de mes
parents j'aurais fini mort coup
moqueries crachat aucun professeur et
personnel encadrant n'a réagi face
caméra certains parents médiatisent le
harcèlement subi par leurs enfants pour
faire bouger les choses
quand il se mettait dans le rang il a
poussé il mettait des coups de ça que
après il attendait à la cantine donc il
encerclé ils attendaient que tout le
monde ait fini de manger l'encerclé il
lui demandait tu es sûr ça va tu es sûr
on sera en rigolant les unes avec les
autres c'était toujours pesant en fait
et une fois ils l'ont même dit de
suicider avec des mots un petit peu plus
vulgaires
je comprends pas qu'on puisse se
réveiller le matin en allant avec ça
comme but dans la vie d'embêter d'autres
enfants selon les dernières statistiques
le harcèlement scolaire toucherait entre
800 000 et 1 million d'élèves chaque
année
alors on a parlé d'éducation je voudrais
qu'on dise un mot des parents parce que
étonnamment ils étaient absents de ce
plan Sarah le grain est-ce que ça vous a
surpris à part de dire que désormais
c'est le harceleur qui quitte l'école et
non pas le harcelé comme c'est trop
souvent le cas
peu de choses sur la responsabilité des
parents pardon mais là d'abord les
parents ils ont un rôle historique dans
la séquence c'est que ce sont des
lanceurs d'alerte de ce que vivent et
subissent leurs enfants parents de
victimes harceler là je parle des
parents mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit
en pointant les parents les uns contre
les autres qu'on règle la question de
l'audience dans la société et de comment
elle se traduit par le harcèle à partir
du moment où vous dites que c'est un
problème qui touche la société
en commission des affaires culturelles
votre collègue madame Carli dire la
solution est-ce que ce ne serait pas de
harceler les harceleurs et ben là vous
avez un adulte qui dit que la réponse à
la violence c'est la violence et c'est
un de vos collègues madame j'en suis
désolé
qui dit que la réponse à la violence et
la violence et ben vous vous dites il y
a quand même quelque chose choses à
faire voilà quand je suis désolé mais
par exemple le fait qu'il faille arrêter
évidemment des enfants qui commettent
des délits leur expliquer que c'est des
délits qu'ils passent devant la justice
c'est essentiel il faut des moyens pour
la justice parce que quand ils vont
traiter tous leurs signalement lâche pas
comment ils vont faire mais c'est vrai
signalement automatique mais d'aller
chercher du procureur ça ne marchera
jamais qu'est-ce que vous mettez
violences faites aux femmes c'est le
chat
d'échec ça veut dire qu'à chaque cas de
signalement il y a une procédure
judiciaire certains enfants de 8 ans 9
ans moi je l'ai dit à Gabriel là on a
vous l'avez dit au ministre du même j'ai
vu donc j'ai vu jeudi pendant 1h30 j'ai
eu la enfin la chance je sais pas en
tout cas l'opportunité de lui dire mon
parcours depuis 10 ans et le parcours de
notre association et des retours des
familles
vous connaissiez la mesure signalement
procureur saisie automatique
c'était déjà dans la note de papédia qui
disait il avait envoyé une note au chef
d'établissement à chaque fois d'annonce
mais ça marche pas mais c'est ça marche
pas je veux dire moi je ne veux pas
judiciariser ce phénomène ce sont encore
des enfants à 10 ans on doit pouvoir les
accompagner et il manque le 100%
accompagnement et prise en charge ce qui
est un triptyque sauf traite qu'on est
aussi ça parce que une fois que l'enfant
il est éventuellement écarté il faut
l'accompagner il faut du suivi
pédagogique du suivi aussi psychologique
un enfant harceleur parfois c'est un
suiveur qui vit d'autre chose qui a
besoin d'être accompagné mais c'est
vraiment ce volet santé mentale prise en
charge et l'aide à la parentalité je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
quand dit que les parents n'ont pas été
évoqués il y a tellement les familles la
pub m'échapper non non mais c'est vrai
il y avait justement je trouvais qu'il y
avait un volet famille qui avait été
présenté par Gabriel attache je me suis
dit enfin il a compris il a compris il
est très intelligent mais il a enfin mis
la famille au cœur du réacteur mais dans
le bon sens du terme pourquoi on doit
développer l'aide à la parentalité et
dans le programme enfin programme de
prévention du harcèlement à l'école
auquel j'ai participé mon volet c'était
la famille parce que je suis une famille
on reçoit des familles en accompagne la
famille depuis Vigipirate suivi de la
covid les parents étaient écartés de
l'établissement ça vous paraît peut-être
anodin mais il y a des enfants
aujourd'hui qui ont peut-être 8 ans en
novembre qui n'ont jamais vu leurs
parents les accompagner dans l'enceinte
de l'école c'est à dire qu'on est devant
le portail donc on était plus convié on
était convoqué j'ai dit des gens on va
changer on va informer qui on est pardon
mais l'éducation nationale comme dans
beaucoup de métiers il y a trop
d'acronymes on va contacter l'ieen qui
verra avec le zazen et peut-être que ce
sera le CPE avec l'interdire à un moment
vous dites j'ai une maladie incurable
bah déjà non mais c'est vrai ça crée de
l'anxiété ça vous fait rire bah non je
connais tous vos acronymes donc je parle
comme vous mais moi en tant que parents
je dis si on me dit je mets en place là
MPP la méthode de la préoccupe
préoccupation partagée parce que j'ai
entendu des chefs d'établissement j'ai
rassuré la famille je leur avais dit
qu'on prenait en charge avec la MPP moi
vous me dites ça je me dis il se passe
quelque chose de grave donc c'est aussi
travailler sur la pédagogie le langage
et faire en sorte que nous par an on est
responsable de nos enfants et on a envie
qu'ils aillent bien à l'école et on doit
les accompagner alors justement ça
m'amène à la dernière mesure et je
voudrais que vous la vous la commentiez
que vous irez peut-être si vous voulez
il y a scène la confiscation du
téléphone portable par la justice et ça
amènera après au bannissement dans
certains cas par les réseaux sociaux
avant même d'ailleurs que le harceleur
soit condamné est-ce que vous pensez que
ces faisable est-ce que après on peut
réussir faire en sorte qu'un enfant ne
retrouve pas un téléphone portable il
trouveront toujours des moyens détournés
et si c'est pas le téléphone ce sera
autre chose de toute façon le
harcèlement j'ai quand même un sentiment
que il vous suit partout moi je sais que
l'individu exactement moi je sais qu'à
l'école primaire il y a des moments
c'était un peu difficile justement dans
les toilettes avec d'autres filles j'ai
un souvenir très net parce qu'en plus ça
nous marque pendant des années et je et
je me souviens que voilà il y avait pas
il y avait pas forcément de téléphone
mais que j'y pensais en rentrant chez
moi donc de toute façon il y avait même
un suivi de la pensée alors c'est sûr
qu'avec les réseaux sociaux ça
s'amplifie mais mais il y a en plus
autre chose c'est que il y a une forme
de honte souvent en parler à ses parents
on se dit bah on est trop faible nos
parents vont nous ils vont nous secouer
ils vont dire bah défends-toi et dans
certaines cultures les notamment les
cultures maghrébines etc dire je suis
une victime ça se dit pas il y a aussi
tout il y a aussi toute cette réflexion
presque culturelle à avoir je trouve et
on sent bien que le voilà le problème
dépasse largement ou quasiment les
frontières même nationales les Gafa on
peut réussir à votre avis aller
d'embarquer pour parvenir à des
bannissement définitifs de Tik Tok par
exemple ou d'Instagram on n'a pas du
tout évoqué ce sujet dans le plan ça a
été évoqué lors de discussion précédente
mais lors de la conférence de presse la
question de la place des réseaux sociaux
n'a pas du tout été évoqué or il y a une
vraie responsabilité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes de moins de 15
ans ont des comptes personne ne contrôle
les réseaux sociaux ne contrôlent rien
or on sait bien que ces réglementé et
donc il y a un vrai sujet sur la place
des propriétaires de ces plateformes qui
doivent être impliquées dans cette
affaire
en ligne il y a des choses qui avancent
mais effectivement ça a pas été dans
l'ordre mais dans le plan aujourd'hui
mais la semaine prochaine on a un texte
qui qui vient dans l'hémicycle et qui
est en partie commence à répondre à ces
enjeux là puisqu'on a des peines qui
vont demander à suspendre les réseaux
sociaux qui vont effectivement
mettre un petit peu plus les réseaux
devant le responsabilité je souhaite
d'ailleurs qu'on aille plus loin
puisqu'on va aller sur la pornographie
mais il faudrait qu'on le mette pour
tout le contrôle de l'âge de moins de 18
ans pour tout les sites y compris pour
les jeux en vidéo en ligne où il y aura
des de l'argent échangé ce qui est
important pour revenir à aujourd'hui
c'est que par contre on en parle de
sensibilisation auprès des parents une
fois par an etc donc ça je pense que ça
peut être intéressant et l'autre point
sur lequel je voulais revenir terminer
ce sera la loi de la fin on parlait des
on parlait des on parlait des harceleurs
et je pense que les harceleurs faut
aussi qu'on s'en occupe parce que
harceleur même si on change d'école si
on s'en occupe pas c'est un enfant qui
pour moi harceleur c'est un enfant aussi
qui est en danger et c'est pour ça que
je trouve que la mesure qui est dire on
aura une enquête un peu idéal pour voir
si cet enfant et pour moi il y a aussi
un phénomène collectif autour parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de camarades sur les
réseaux sociaux attention à des mesures
qui sont proprement inapplicables je
vois pas comment vous la justice
garantie qu'un enfant n'a plus de
téléphone je vois pas comment même avec
le numérique aujourd'hui je vois pas
comment sauf à contrevenir avec les
questions Daniel animal etc et ça
soulève plein de questions de liberté
vous commencez à bannir quelqu'un mais
qui puisse plus jamais créer de compte
et par ailleurs vous avez montré quoi
tout à l'heure sur la libération de la
parole des tweets c'est quoi les réseaux
sociaux c'est un immense vous avez parlé
d'espace d'information c'est un immense
espace où on informe et où on est
violent et si on régule pas la société
et les échanges entre les personnes et
si on n'applique pas déjà la loi
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
insultes qui sont interdites et sur la
justice est en incapacité de condamner
des gens pour des insultes qu'ils font
publiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas à cause des plateformes c'est
parce qu'on a une justice à bout et
parce qu'on a une société où les
violences se démultipliquement donc
attention à ces mesures gadgets qui
peuvent aboutir à être au minimum
inefficace voire extrêmement dangereuse
pour pour nos libères en tout cas merci
on va
les élus les enseignants les associatifs
on va laisser quelques mois à ce plan on
verra comment il se déploie mais on a
entendu attention aux effets d'annonce
vous restez avec moi Lilia Hassen dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nos affranchis ce soir l'Europe avec
Richard Verly la France l'Allemagne en
mieux vraiment l'oeil sur le numérique
de Thomas l'estavel avec un carton rouge
de Bruxelles à Elon Musk et puis un
Bourbon Express spécial budget 2024 et
c'est vous qui nous le présentez Fanny
un mot pour qualifier ce budget et bien
peut-être un budget qui n'évitera pas un
49-3 voilà encore un mais d'abord à tout
à l'heure les amis on va plonger dans
votre livre Lilia scène panorama chez
Gallimard raconte la France je le disait
de 2049 où le peuple et bien se rebelle
pour lutter contre toutes les formes de
violences en créant une société de la
transparence où tout se sait et où tout
se voit et vous allez le voir et bien ça
crée quelques problèmes regardez c'est
dans l'invitation d'Elsa mandingavard
avec Maïté Frémont et puis on en parle
juste après
si on vous invite il y a à scène c'est
parce que vous nous transportez dans un
futur inquiétant mais pas si loin de
nous 2050 à peine 30 ans dans une France
ou règne la transparence avec un Grand T
et où les Français vivent dans des
maisons vitrées pour ne rien cacher
alors voisin enfin sur le papier Lilia
Hassen vous êtes diplômé de l'Institut
français de la presse avant de vous
découvrir romancière on vous a connu
chroniqueuse dans l'émission à succès
quotidien tu vas nous manquer à tous
mais au-delà de ça je voulais simplement
te remercier pour ton travail te
remercie pour ta confiance et te
remercier pour ton amitié j'ai hâte de
te recevoir pour je sais pas ton
troisième livre et panorama est
justement votre troisième publication
après l'oeil du Pan et soleil amer un
roman très bien accueilli par la
critique
génialissime pour RTL un roman
indispensable pour le point
social et génial pour le Parisien un
régal de lecture pour Libération
panorama une plongée dans une France qui
pense que la transparence et la solution
à tous ces problèmes mais vous en
démontrez rapidement les limites dans la
transparence que je décris dans le livre
chaque citoyen doit quand même remplir
une déclaration citoyenne où il doit
donner ses informations personnelles et
cette déclaration est visible de tous
donc si on constate un manquement chez
un voisin on est évidemment appelé à non
pas le dénoncer puisqu'on est dans une
société où on ne parle pas de
dénonciation mais à le faire valoir
dans cette enquête policière vous
poussez à l'extrême des tendances qui
existent déjà l'influence des réseaux
sociaux l'intérêt pour les autres qui se
transforment en voyeurisme le mirage
d'une sécurité retrouvée au sacrifice de
la vie privée alors une question ce soir
il y a scène nous sommes nous pas déjà
dans l'ère de la transparence à tout
prix
alors réponse Lilia scène oui si j'ai
écrit ce livre c'était pour c'est une
légère anticipation en fait
effectivement c'est seulement
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure on parlait
des toilettes
lieu de harcèlement demain peut-être des
toilettes transparentes avec les
systèmes que j'ai inventé dans le livre
pour pouvoir surveiller les les jeunes
justement en vous lisant on va revenir
un peu à l'univers que vous créez c'est
pas vraiment une dystopie c'est une
sorte de contre-utopie on va y venir
dans le détail mais je me suis demandé
si vous l'aimiez vous la détestiez notre
époque
en plus dans le livre je ce que quelque
part le monde d'avant où je décris dans
le livre qui a un monde un peu plus
idéal c'est le monde aujourd'hui c'est
laisser notre époque c'est à dire je
tire jusqu'en 2029 2049 et là ça devient
très compliqué mais
dans cette vie de 2049 même dans la
société de la transparence avec un Grand
T au fond il y a quand même des bons
côtés c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est ambivalent c'est à la fois un
enfer cette ville où tout se voit tout
se sait en permanence où on vit sous
l'oeil de ses voisins du matin au soir
mais en même temps il y a de la
bienveillance on est plus attentif aux
autres donc c'est ambivalent on parle
des cours d'empathie et de bienveillance
c'est tout à fait dans ma dans mon ma
contre utopie mais effectivement c'est
une société c'est une société plutôt de
la bienveillance une société
où on a réussi à laisser le seuil de
criminalité on a réussi à baisser les
violences les maltraitances comme c'est
des tout est vitrées les abattoirs sont
vitrés donc les gens arrêtent un peu de
manger de la viande parce qu'ils
prennent conscience donc il y a toute
cette partie qui est assez positive et
j'avais à cœur justement que ce soit pas
manichéen bien sûr on se dise ça c'est
très réussi d'ailleurs qu'on se dise ça
pourrait c'est crédible complètement
crédible alors cette société de la
transparence elle se met pas en place du
jour au lendemain il y a un événement
déclencheur en 2029 un influenceur à
succès révèle qu'il a été victime d'abus
sexuel et il demande à sa communauté si
il faut qu'il se fasse vengeance
lui-même et là résultat unanime c'est
oui
exactement j'avais réfléchi aux raisons
pour lesquelles on arrivera à cette
société de la transparence et il me
semblait que que la justice était
vraiment une sorte de nœud gardien de
toutes les de toutes les tensions aussi
aujourd'hui on vient de le voir tout à
l'heure sur les questions de harcèlement
c'est le cas sur la question de l'État
de droit c'est le cas voilà c'est le cas
pour à la fois pour l'extrême droite
c'est pour la gauche pour le centre
c'est vraiment le cas pour toute la
classe politique il y a quand même une
remise en cause de de la justice et le
fait que on arrive dans une société de
plus en plus ongère ou quand il y a un
fait divers par exemple certaines
émissions de télé aujourd'hui n'hésite
pas à proposer des sondages c'est une
chose qui m'a extrêmement intéressé je
me souviens qu'au moment de l'écriture
de lit du livre j'avais à faire Lola et
de nombreux faits divers et quand
j'allume ma télévision on demandait à
des chroniqueurs qui étaient pas du tout
qualifiés sur les questions judiciaires
elle ne va pas du tout penser de
trancher et de dire à ce qu'il faut un
procès est-ce qu'il faut injustice
expéditive
et puis comme on demande la la box
populi on demande sur les réseaux
sociaux aux gens de réagir et réagissent
avec émotion donc c'est ce n'est pas
dans un vote on est dans un sondage
alors après voilà cette justice cette
vengeance il va y avoir une semaine
particulière ou alors là c'est le
déchaînement toutes les victimes
deviennent des agresseurs ça s'appelle
la reven week c'est quoi alors c'est une
semaine effectivement de vengeance mais
les gens se vengent tous pour des bonnes
raisons c'est à dire qu'on va se manger
contre un prêtre pédophile on va se
venger contre un flic abusif on va se
venger il y a des militants écolos qui
qui tuent le président d'un empire
pétrolier enfin tout le monde a des
bonnes raisons en réalité pour pour se
ranger et le phénomène prend une telle
ampleur qu'au bout de qu'au bout d'un
moment ça devient complètement ingérable
incontrôlable et surtout effectivement
avec un soutien des réseaux sociaux ce
qui ce qui fait que on bascule dans on
passe d'un état de droit à une forme de
démocratie qui est plus tellement
démocratique du tribunal populaire pour
sortir de cette vengeance de tous contre
tous ou là c'est le déchaînement de
violence il y a une avocate et un
architecte qui s'associe et qui décide
au fond de faire une nouvelle
constitution et de proposer cette idée
d'ailleurs ce serait une forme de
principe constitutionnel de la
transparence et cette transparence elle
va s'incarner grâce à un architecte qui
va tout révolutionner et c'est ces
fameuses maisons vivarium ces
appartements tout en vert ces maisons
bulles d'où vous est venu cette idée-là
ou finalement on pourrait vivre sous
l'oeil de tous alors bon l'idée de
départ c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
une vision purement esthétique de des
salles de bains les magasins
d'ameublement qu'on voit dans la rue et
on a l'impression un peu d'être chez les
gens on a tous un peu ce sentiment quand
parfois on regarde par la fenêtre de son
immeuble on est attiré par les voisins
donc il y avait bon ces questions qui
étaient déjà là et puis il me semblait
que le vert ce matériau disait beaucoup
de notre époque et des contradictions de
notre époque aussi c'est à dire que
c'est à la fois fragile et solide c'est
à la fois l'ouverture et la fermeture
parce que ce que ce que j'écris dans le
livre on voit ce qui se passe au travers
et en même temps on ne se touche pas il
y a une forme de distance avec le vert
qui est assez intéressante et puis et
puis c'est un matériau qui qui as une
forme de dématérialisation aussi donc on
est toujours entre le réel et le virtuel
aussi j'avais des petits détails qui
croient vraiment que ça peut arriver les
oiseaux peuvent pas se cogner contre les
vides parce que il y a des petites
rainures que seuls les animaux peuvent
voir et par les humains donc tout a été
parfaitement pensé évidemment c'est
l'auto régulation il y a même pas besoin
de délation tout le monde se surveille
et personne voilà ne contrevient aux
règles de cette fameuse bienveillance et
donc il y a plus besoin de police dans
ce monde là la police est aux terrasse
sans armes c'est effectivement on a plus
besoin de se surveiller d'ailleurs le
mot surveillance n'existe plus tellement
on parle de protection les policiers
sont devenus des gardiens de protection
parce que ils ont pu grand rôle à jouer
ils ont un rôle administratif ils font
des tourner dans des tournées de
voisinages où il recueille un peu les
paroles de certains qui voilà quand on
se plaint d'un voisin c'est mais ils ont
une fonction très absolument mineur
jusqu'à la disparition d'une fameuse
famille
et voyez du Mas ce qui est important
aussi c'est de bien expliquer que dans
cette
contre-utopie où tout est possible tout
est crédible on est arrivé là par un
choix démocratique c'est le peuple qui
l'a décidé personne ne l'a forcé en fait
c'est même pas une dystopie parce que
dans une dystopie il y a un pouvoir
autoritaire une sorte de Big Brother là
non c'est vraiment un choix exactement
il y a pas de figure je voulais pas
qu'il y ait figure de dictateur
contrairement à de nombreuses dystopies
je voulais je j'ai pensé que la dystopie
une dystopie du 21e siècle serait une
dystopie de l'autorégulation des
citoyens qui jouent les uns contre les
autres en pensant jouer les uns avec les
autres que ce soit vraiment que chacun
surveille l'autre sans dire qu'on se
surveille et où chacun donne beaucoup
aussi de lui-même c'est ce qui est c'est
ce qui est très intéressant d'ailleurs
avec les réseaux sociaux c'est qu'on a
le sentiment d'être libre et donc on
donne de nombreuses informations
volontairement pensant que pensant qu'on
exerce là notre liberté et donc
effectivement c'est une société qui est
une société totalement horizontale avec
un contrôle horizontal et c'est
tellement bien fait que et tellement
choisi qu'on peut toujours refuser cette
société et aller vivre au grillon c'est
quoi les grillons bien sûr c'est une
société justement de on ne veut pas
imposer on n'est pas dans une dictature
on le répète et donc il y a un quartier
dans lequel on peut faire le choix
d'habiter c'est un choix qui se paye ce
que je disais tout à l'heure dans le
dans le petit extrait que vous avez
montré il faut remplir une déclaration
pour pour dire qu'on renonce assez droit
enfin que la police n'interviendra pas
en fait c'est le principe de la
responsabilité individuelle vous
choisissez de vivre hors de la
transparence donc d'une sorte d'utopie
où tout le monde côtoie tout le monde et
tout le monde le sait mais et voilà donc
faites ce choix là vous vivez dans un
quartier dangereux puisque c'est un
quartier avec des murs et bien dans ce
cas il faut en assumer les conséquences
et vous pouvez pas appeler la police et
vous pouvez pas appeler les services
d'urgence mais au moins de rayon il y a
une la différence il y a encore de la
différence parce que ce qui se passe
avec cette société de la transparence
c'est que finalement c'est la société de
l'entre-soi qui se recrée il y a des
ghettos des ghettos des guêpes les
ghettos des féministes les dégots des
écolos et c'est comme sur les réseaux
sociaux finalement sauf que c'est dans
la vraie vie le mot de communauté sur
les réseaux sociaux il me frappe
toujours parce que on est dans un dans
un justement une démocratie qui qui
n'aime pas le communautarisme et qui qui
explique toujours qu'il faut lutter
contre le communautarisme mais en fait
on recrée plein de communautés de gens
d'accord entre eux qui qui se confortent
dans leurs opinions qui sont confortés
dans leurs opinions tout ça dans des
buts enfin c'est une manière d'alimenter
le capitalisme c'est le grand jeu que je
joue c'est les réseaux sociaux c'est
vous conforter dans vos croyances et
donc voilà je voulais vraiment que on
retrouve dans cette société parfaite
sort de vivre ensemble entre soi ou les
gens acceptent de vivre ensemble
mais ne veulent plus voir à partir du
moment où on voit nos voisins en
permanence on veut voir que ceux qui
nous ressemblent
plus tellement effectivement la
différence c'est vrai c'est qu'il y a la
différence c'est quand même reste quand
même social entre les grillons et et les
autres quartiers parce que ça c'est
différences sociales j'ai l'impression
qu'on peut quand même pas les effacer et
évidemment il y a une intrigue un drame
se produit on va pas raconter la suite
une famille disparaît comment est-ce
possible dans cette société là il faut
lire et c'est un régal de lecture
panorama chez Gallimard c'est vraiment
très réussi et je peux vous dire que
c'est partagé par l'ensemble de la
rédaction de SCP vous restez avec moi
Lilia Hassen c'est l'heure d'accueillir
nos affranchis vous allez voir leur
partie prix vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite
Richard Werly et son regard sur l'Europe
du quotidien suisse Blic bienvenue
Thomas l'estavel pour l'économie et le
numérique bienvenue à tous les doigts va
commencer comme chaque soir par bonbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nous emmène du côté de Bercy et aussi de
la commission des finances puisqu'on
parle budget 2024 et qui mieux que Fanny
guinochet pour nous présenter ce budget
Fanny de France Info et de la tribune
budget à 16 milliards d'euros
d'économies exactement 16 milliards
d'euros d'économies c'est quand même une
somme conséquente et c'est une équation
presque insoluble pour le gouvernement
qui veut continuer à soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des Français le gros de ces 16
milliards d'euros d'économies provenant
des boucliers de la fin des boucliers
tarifaires notamment sur l'énergie mais
Bruno Le Maire ce matin a répété que sa
priorité c'était la lutte contre
l'inflation c'est son défi le combat du
gouvernement et il veut aussi se
projeter de loi de finance répondre aux
attentes des Français et Bruno le Maire
le ministre de l'Économie a donc
détaillé les grands choix d'avenir pour
ce projet de loi de finances on l'écoute
la sécurité et le régalien avec les lois
de programmation sur la justice sur la
police et sur les armées qui seront
scrupuleusement respectés la priorité
donnée par le Président de la République
à l'éducation et à la santé et enfin le
choix de politique décisif en faveur de
la décarbonation et de la transition
écologique rappelée par le Président de
la République lundi et pas la première
ministre hier soir alors vous voyez la
liste est longue et alors ensuite Bruno
Le Maire a décliné augmentation de la
prime rénov augmentation des bonus des
voitures en leasing à 100 euros etc etc
ça fait beaucoup mais c'est pas du tout
un budget d'austérité non oui c'est
pourtant comme ça que les oppositions
ont tendance à le qualifier notamment
les oppositions sur les qui sont le plus
à gauche de l'échiquier politique mais
l'austérité ce serait renié par exemple
sur les pensions de retraite or dans son
budget on découvre aussi aujourd'hui que
elles vont être revalorisées de 5,2%
pour suivre l'inflation ce budget index
aussi les minimas sociaux à 4,6%, il
relève le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu tout ça c'est quand même une
enveloppe de 25 milliards d'euros et en
même temps en même temps on a un Bruno
Le Maire qui insiste lourdement sur le
désendettement sur le fait que la France
est beaucoup trop endettée et qu'il faut
que l'État ne peut pas tout il faut dire
qu'avec la flambée des taux d'intérêt et
bien la charge de la dette c'est-à-dire
le poids juste des intérêts explosent 74
milliards d'euros bientôt c'est plus que
le budget de l'Éducation nationale qui
est pourtant notre premier budget et
Bruno Le Maire l'a dit ce matin sans
concession
moi je vais vous dire ça me fait mal au
cœur d'avoir une charge de la dette qui
soit aussi élevée car c'est de l'argent
jeté par les fenêtres ça suffit et je le
dis à tous ceux qui étaient pensés plus
pas de problème avec la dette
endettez-vous davantage mais quand on a
du taux d'intérêt à 4% c'est totalement
irresponsable de plaider pour un
allourdissement de la dette et de la
charge de la dette
alors pour le vote de ce budget voilà
vous l'entendez justement il parle de
responsabilité et il en appelle à la
responsabilité des députés pour voter ce
texte pourtant on va quand même tout
droit vers le 49-3 et bien c'est
probable parce que sans majorité absolue
on sait que voter le budget signifie
pour les oppositions et bien rejoindre
la majorité ça semble intenable
d'ailleurs Elisabeth borne la première
ministre l'addition des tours il y a
quelques jours aux journées
parlementaires de renaissance bon
toutefois là quand même dit qu'elle
laissait la place au débat avant de
faire tomber le fameux coup près du 49.3
l'examen du projet de loi de finances va
débuter le 17 octobre dans l'hémicy
merci beaucoup Fanny on verra si les
Français se s'habituent ou pas le débat
avant le 49-3 c'est on verra ça en tout
cas on utilise démocratique de près
alors justement comment va la France on
vient de le voir avec la présentation du
budget Richard Verly on connaît un petit
peu le refrain trop d'impôts trop
dépense publique sauf que surprise
l'Allemagne commence à regarder un peu
de près notre modèle et nous jalouse
elle parle même d'un modèle français
alors je sais ce que vous avez en tête
Myriam vous avez lu Der Spiegel le très
influant magazine allemand allez avouer
vous avez même pris du plaisir à of
Deutsch en lisant l'enquête sur la
France publié début septembre par
l’hebdomadaire de Hambourg c'est la
ville du chancelier Olaf scholls une
phrase choc avait alors retenu
l'attention des commentateurs y compris
Fanny Guy nocher j'en suis sûr la France
est aujourd'hui l'Allemagne en mieux
waouh fini les reproches sur les 3000
milliards d'euros des publics fini le
refus d'émettre à nouveau des emprunts
européens mutualisés fini l'arrogance
industrielle germanique et bien non raté
car ce n'est pas le modèle budgétaire
français bref la gestion et le train de
vie de l'État que les Allemands nous
envient pour eux et ça ne vous attend ça
ne vous étonnera pas comme pour tous les
pays du Nord habitués à compter leurs
sous la France continue de trop dépenser
comme je viens de le dire toujours le
maire on oubliant qu’un emprunt c'est
aussi un créancier donc une faiblesse en
cas de crise et de remontée de taux
d'intérêt ce que les Allemands regardent
c'est ce qu'a réussi Emmanuel Macron
s'est affaire renaître l'attractivité
française c'est ici en France que les
investisseurs étrangers place leur
capitaux c'est ici que vont ouvrir les
usines de batterie électrique les plus
importantes d'Europe et puis il y a le
made in France qui continue à caracoler
dans le luxe avec une très forte valeur
ajoutée tout cela en s'appuyant sur deux
leviers que les Allemands n'ont pas le
premier c'est l'énergie nucléaire et le
deuxième c'est la centralisation à
Berlin on reste scotché avec le gaz qui
n'est plus russe mais donc on fait du
charbon et avec le fédéralisme et une
coalition de plus en plus difficile à
gérer entre vers libéraux et
sociaux-démocrate bref l'Allemagne elle
redoute de perdre son atout c'était la
productivité avec ses voitures
thermiques qui sont bientôt condamnés
alors est-ce que c'est qu'une victoire
française on en est pas là mais Paris le
pays du panier percé a peut-être quand
même gagné cette nouvelle bataille du
Rhin cocorico pour une fois les
Allemands nous trouvent un peu
intéressant même mieux que ça fait du
bien allez on va garder cette note
positive Thomas vous vouliez revenir sur
ce qui s'est passé hier à Bruxelles la
Commission européenne s'en est prise
publiquement à X elle dénonce le peu de
moyens que déploie Twitter pour lutter
contre la désinformation c'est
l'occasion pour vous de pousser un gros
coup de gueule exactement Myriam alors
depuis le rachat par le patron de Tesla
c'est un peu open bar donc on a les
comptes qui avait été bannis jusque là
qui ont bénéficié d'une amnistie
générale tant pis il est contre vérité
circulent sur Twitter le problème c'est
comme vous l'avez dit depuis un mois on
a une législation européenne qui oblige
les grandes plateformes comme Twitter
Facebook etc à modérer davantage les
contenus et l'Oiseau Bleu dernier de la
classe avec le plus grand ratio de des
informations s'expose à une amende de 6%
de son chiffre d'affaires théoriquement
du mois et c'est pas la première fois
que Twitter est sous le feu des
critiques alors effectivement alors il y
a trois mois il y a eu un événement
intéressant de dirigeants du réseau
social qui ont quitté l'entreprise suite
à une polémique un tweet qui faisait la
promotion d'un documentaire transphobe
avait d'abord été retiré par l'équipe de
modération de X qui en avait limité la
visibilité mais Elon Musk reste tout
puissant dans son entreprise il a décidé
d'annuler cette action et il a même fait
la promotion de ce documentaire sur son
propre compte sur X on trouve de
nombreuses fake news par exemple pas
très il y a pas très longtemps des
soi-disant laboratoires qui
fabriqueraient des armes biologiques en
Ukraine probablement des hackers russes
il y a pas que Twitter qui est montré du
doigt oui effectivement alors on sait on
se souvient par exemple des élections
américaines ou du brexit dont les
résultats avaient été influencés
directement par des campagnes de
désinformation provenant probablement de
hacker russe ou chinois d'après le média
en ligne the canversation certaines
histoires de désinformation de facebook
tous jusqu'à 200 millions de personnes
ça veut dire trois fois la France c'est
à dire
alors en fait il y a une forme
d'innaction de la part des plateformes
parce que modérer des contenus d'après
en tout cas ça demande évidemment du
fact checking donc des recrutements et
ça coûte un peu d'argent rien
d'insurmontable par rapport au budget de
segafa les plateformes évoquent aussi
leur attachement la liberté d'expression
mais ça c'est un peu un prétexte et la
réalité est moins reluisante et donc
alors voilà en fait Elon Musk avait
déclaré à propos du tweet sur le fameux
documentaire transforme et phrase très
intéressantes la polémique va augmenter
l'audimat et tout est là pour gagner les
utilisateurs donc des annonceurs les
plateformes ont besoin de contenu viraux
et les propos extrêmes les propos
simpliste les propos controversés
excitent notre cerveau et nous rendre
encore plus accros donc Twitter et les
autres n'ont aucun intérêt économique à
modérer leur contenu des publications
plus équilibrées plus sensées c'est plus
ennuyeux et ça rapporte moins moralité
vous ne pourrez jamais compter sur la
bonne volonté de Zuckerberg ou de musk
pour faire la police sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut sanctionner sans
modération d'accord avec avec ça oui
c'est le serpent qui qui se mord la
queue complètement et puis on le voit de
façon les émotions dominantes c'est
c'est la peur la colère qui nous rende
aussi accro aux réactions et donc c'est
c'est toute une vie c'est toute une
réaction en chaîne et je dans la France
de 2049 un monde sans réseau sociaux
c'est possible j'ai joué justement là
dessus il y en a pas beaucoup parce que
justement ces réseaux sociaux dans la
vraie vie mais c'est vrai que même les
réseaux sociaux dans la vraie vie ça
crée des des communautés c'est sorte de
de crédit en fait c'est drôle parce
qu'on parle de la Chine et de la
surveillance on parle du Crédit Social
nous ce qu'on fait avec nos réseaux
sociaux c'est une forme de nouveaux
crédit social c'est de nombre d'abonnés
nous permet d'accéder à des soirées nous
permet de recevoir des cadeaux et en
fait ils ont réussi à créer avec le
sentiment de la liberté des conditions à
la fois de surveillance de manipulation
de l'opinion qui sont quand même assez
terrifiants et d'une certaine façon
panorama c'est un véritable
avertissement merci beaucoup un livre à
la fois littéraire politique dystopique
chez Gallimard pas lire d'urgence merci
les affranchis et on va se quitter avec
une petite image parce qu'elle s'est
fait partenaire ce soir des Trophées des
trophées sport et management vous voyez
ils sont remis tout à l'heure c'était
tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée cérémonie
avec plusieurs sportifs qui récompensent
chaque année les acteurs de terrain
associatifs élus ou fédération qui
rassemble crée du commun grâce au sport
très belle soirée pour voir ou revoir
cette émission la chaîne Youtube encore
les réseaux de notre chaîne LCP à demain
[Musique]